ladies headsets oven please direct your
attention to the front of the cabin for
your safety please unbuckle your seat
belts beverages beverages snacks
beverages beverages beverages snacks yes
can i stow that for you said your dad is
going to love this
that summer vacation ever I gotta warn
you I played second team co-ed
intramural volleyball at Santa Cruz
DJ Jazzy Johnny in the happy surprise oh
my gosh this is gonna be so much fun
I've taken care of everything so you
don't need to worry you've been so
stressed out lately
good evening travelers I am professor
Abraham Van Helsing yes one of the Van
Helsing's
fear not for I am a professional and I
know how to flush out these beasts and
bring them into the light
finally first I kill Dracula and then
the rest of the monsters welcome to the
Bermuda Triangle where you'll embark on
a monster cruise of a lifetime do what
about here that's right what exactly
don't you understand man this is amazing
there's so much to do whoa give me a
seaweed rewrap whoa who is that I and
yes I'm human but don't hold that
against me I could not be more excited
to have all of you on board our first
ever monster cruise so you must be the
one and only Dracula oh that was
incredible
hey Murray here may be from Egypt but
you're the one in denial ha ha ha
do you guys get that ow you get me right
now
Oh watch where you're pointing mister
I'm right here okay Drac hit it this is
like the nicest hotel I've ever been to
yeah everybody just please watch the
hair watch the hair
no you don't last time you gambled you
lost an arm and a leg literally Frank
would you rub some moon screen on my
back before I get burned this is Bob say
hi Bob oh come on pop a dress
there you are tinkles don't worry almost
there
you